Mark Norman
hey good to be here how you doing Mel uh
doing a lot of drinking here you know
people always talk about how honest you
are when you're drunk I feel like I'm
way more honest when I'm hungover you
know when I'm drunk I can lie all day
cops like you've been drinking I'm like
no way
when I'm hungover that's when I'm honest
my life's in shambles I have nothing to
live for you know your friend's like you
want to get brunch you're like I've
never liked you
everything's a lie when you're drunk you
know you're like hey it's the best night
ever these are my good friends and she's
super hot then you wake up like as a
waste of time I spent too much money and
that's a dude
I blacked out last week that's
embarrassing yeah I told my roommate
he's like oh yeah blacked out that means
you forgot to brush your teeth last
night I was like wow that is the least
of my worries yeah I'm more concerned
with the lipstick I'm wearing why I sent
my mom a dick pic
yeah
I don't know drink a lot a single guy
it's scary to hit on girls you gotta
drink for that you know it's hard to hit
on girls I feel like women should on men
more hit on us ladies when's that
feminist Moon we're gonna kick in you
know you can say whatever you want to a
guy I had an older lady approach me once
she goes ooh I'm gonna kidnap you I was
like wow I could never say that to a
woman
I say that to a lady she calls the
police I would be curious to know what a
woman could say that would offend me
like all right I'm gonna take you home
drug you take advantage of you and film
it I'd be like all right well at least
let me pay for the Uber
[Music]
this is how sexy girls are I was out to
dinner once this girl leans over during
the meal and goes hey I'm not wearing
any underwear I was like oh my God
that's hot then I realized why is that
sexy has underwear ever been a huge
obstacle for a guy has any guy ever
taken a girl's jeans off seeing panties
have been like it's gonna be a long
night
what a pot of coffee on I can't crack
that code
well that's how hot you are gals you can
tell my article of clothing you're not
wearing I can't even see it missing I'm
already turned on
doesn't work for me as a guy I can't
pull that off I lean over during dinner
hey I'm not wearing any underwear she's
gonna go uh oh what happened
laundry day diarrhea native wet wipe
talk to me
I don't know It's just tough to date now
you know we have no patience anymore we
want everything immediately now we want
anything quick we want Uber Tinder
Netflix everything's so quick now the
only thing we don't want quickest sex
what is that going to catch up
I was with a girl the other night I
finished kind of early she's like hey
what's going on here I was like well
these are the times we're living in
I don't the patience for your vagina to
be buffering let's go
you're an analog girl doing a digital
world sister pick it up
I don't know maybe I'm screwed up
sexually you know I caught my parents
having sex so I was 8 21 and today and
uh the idea of your parents having sex
is so horrifying isn't it that's why I'm
surprised parents don't use that as a
threat
right wouldn't that be so effective like
hey Tim you better clean that room me
and your mom are gonna go at it
I know that math test Billy I got a D
I'll show you some D all right I'm sorry
oh yeah just found out my
ex-girlfriend's getting breast implants
that blew my mind I use the term breast
implants I don't like the term fake
breasts doesn't make sense to me because
the breasts are real it's just the
inside that's fake the breasts are still
real it's kind of like the Bible the
book is real it's just the inside
it's fake
another another book
Yeah Boy the Bible's a real Buzz Kill
huh what a bummer they don't like
anything fun in the Bible they hate gays
they hate trans that's gonna be great
we're doing stuff so sexually Advanced
not even in the Bible you know like I
love my vacuum cleaner the guy's
like
all right you're good
maybe I'll try it yeah and I don't
know some people probably offended some
people get so mad when you make fun of
their religion which I never got if you
believe it just believe it what does it
matter what I say like I believe in
gravity if somebody's like hey gravity's
not real I'd be like all right good luck
out there
I wouldn't be mad I'm just like hey stay
off the roof buddy yeah all right
I will say this about uh dating I'm sick
of good looking people there's none here
so we're good but you know
beautiful people I'm done with you you
know like I can't relate you don't know
what it's like it's like there like I
want to deal with this girl recently she
was so pretty this girl was gorgeous
beautiful beautiful woman way out of my
league but she had nothing to say she
was boring so I kind of checked out and
she goes look I can tell you don't like
me just want to sleep with me and I was
like well yeah but that's your fault
and she was like you a more is a
pretty face I'm like but that's all you
worked on
hours on your hair makeup outfit get a
knock knock joke together
I don't get these good-looking people
they spend 100 of their time on their
looks zero on their personality you just
assume that part's amazing why wouldn't
you work on that too give it 80 20. 80
20. go to the gym all day put makeup on
and watch half a documentary half yeah
I know I'm not a hot guy you know before
date I'm writing jokes in my hand
limericks anecdotes I'm bringing it baby
I'm tap dancing out there you know
like if a girl told me Mark you're funny
but you're not that hot I'd be like I
know that's why I'm funny
all right thanks a lot have a good night